Welcome to this deep dive so imagine going to a clinic with like a clearly broken arm, right?
You're in a lot of pain exactly, but instead of taking an x-ray the doctor just hands you a calendar
That would be completely absurd. I mean in the world of physical medicine. It's ridiculous
You want to see the jagged white line on the bone you point to it and you fix it
Yeah, you want that visible binary category. It's either broken or it's not
But in the world of human emotion specifically, you know clinical sadness the calendar isn't just a tool
It is literally the ultimate judge. It really is. We we desperately want mental health to operate like orthopedics
But a psychiatric diagnosis involves mapping this totally invisible terrain, which is incredibly hard
Oh, it's incredibly hard. The challenge isn't figuring out if a patient is suffering
It's that near identical types of suffering require wildly different treatments and giving the wrong treatment can be disastrous
So today we are looking at how the medical establishment attempts to put a ruler next to that human suffering
We're diving into this really fascinating source
Yeah
It's an expert medical exam prep guide right by an instructor named keek from a program called pass ready prep
And her guide is designed for medical professionals focusing heavily on what she calls the traps
Looking at how doctors are actually tested is just a brilliant framework for understanding how medicine views depression because it's not just theory, right?
Exactly exam prep isn't about memorizing a list of symptoms in a vacuum
It is about learning the precise
Razor thin boundaries that separate one diagnosis from another and the exam writers know where people mess up. Oh, totally
They design questions specifically to fool test takers into making the exact same misdiagnoses
That happen every single day in real clinics. Wow
So our mission for this deep dive is to decode five specific depressive disorders from keek's guide, right?
We are going to bypass the heavy medical jargon
Examine those boundaries and uncover why misdiagnosing these conditions is an actual clinical danger. Not just a paperwork error
Exactly. So let's start with the baseline. The condition keek calls the anchor of all depressive diagnoses
major depressive disorder
Or mdd right so keek maps this out starting with the clinical codes
Uh, it's f32 for a single episode and f33 for recurrent
Okay, got it. And the clinical picture requires five or more symptoms to be present for a minimum of two weeks
But there is a totally non-negotiable rule buried in those symptoms, isn't there there is because a patient could have like
severe insomnia terrible fatigue
Drastic weight loss and inability to concentrate that's four symptoms right there, right
But if they don't have either a profoundly depressed mood or anhedonia
Which is the loss of interest in things they usually enjoy exactly if they don't have one of those two
It simply isn't major depressive disorder. That's fascinating. Yeah, anhedonia is the linchpin of the diagnosis
It is a complete mechanical failure of the brain's reward system. So they aren't just sad about missing a hobby
No, they literally cannot process the sensation of pleasure like the food they love tastes like cardboard
The music they love just sounds like static
So for treatment the guide outlines this dual ponged approach for moderate to severe
MDD right a combination of an ssri medication and psychotherapy typically cognitive behavioral therapy or cbt
Yeah, this dual approach attacks the mechanism of the disorder from two completely different angles. How so well the ssri works on the biological hardware
It gradually raises the neurochemical floor
So the patient has the physical energy to even engage and the cbt cbt operates on the software
It provides the architectural scaffolding to rebuild
Uh, you know a shattered self-esteem and correct the severe cognitive distortions that mdd creates
So you need the floor to stand on and the scaffolding to climb out?
That's a perfect way to put it but let me play devil's advocate here regarding the hardware of this diagnosis the two-week floor
Okay, sure. I look at an mdd episode as a sudden heavy anchor dropping on someone's chest
It just pulls them underwater. But why is the medical cut off exactly 14 days, right biologically speaking
Day 13 and day 14 feel completely identical to the person who's drowning. Oh, absolutely
So telling someone on day 13 to like come back tomorrow to be officially depressed
I mean that feels like a bureaucratic technicality not science
Well, you are hitting on the fundamental messiness of the dsm the diagnostic and statistical manual
Biology does not carry a stopwatch. Exactly. The two-week rule is not a law of nature. It's a consensus document
Human committees literally sat in rooms and argued over where to draw the line. So they just guessed I wouldn't say guest
They optimize for reliability. What do you mean?
Well in order to run a clinical trial to prove that a new SSRI actually works
You have to ensure that the people in the trial are experiencing a sustained state of pathology
Oh not just having a transient reaction to a really terrible week
Exactly because if doctors all use different timelines the research data just collapses
The 14 day floor is essentially the line in the sand
Separating a severe mood fluctuation from a condition that requires clinical intervention. That makes sense
And that actually brings us directly into the first major trap. Kick warns her test takers about the grief trap
Oh, this is a big one. Yeah a patient comes into the clinic
They are grieving a massive loss say the death of a spouse and they look profoundly depressed because they are in
Incredible pain right they hit all five symptoms on the checklist
They have the insomnia the weight loss the depressed mood and it's been over two weeks
A clinician's natural instinct there is to relieve pain. Of course when a doctor sees a patient in that much agony
The reflex is to reach for the prescription pad
But keek's guide explicitly warns against reflexively medicating morning
So the trap is failing to differentiate the mechanism of grief from the pathology of mdd precisely the source highlights two major separators here
First grief comes in waves like a wave hits you you feel entirely overwhelmed, but then the wave recedes slightly
Yeah, you might even laugh at a fond memory of the person you lost before the next wave hits, right?
But mdd doesn't recede that anchor stays dropped and the second even more critical separator is self-esteem
Oh, this part was really striking in normal grief a person's fundamental sense of self-worth usually stays intact
The pain is externally focused on the loss
They feel empty because the person is gone. But in a true major depressive episode the pain turns inward
Exactly. The self-esteem is pulverized the patient feels inherently
Worthless or toxic or like they're just a burden to those around them
So a doctor mistaking grief for mdd might throw an antidepressant at a patient who is simply experiencing the deeply human
Necessary process of mourning which is a powerful reminder that not all pain is a disease. Absolutely
So we've explored depression measured by a rigid 14-day calendar
But the diagnostic landscape shifts dramatically when we look at the limitations of that acute time frame, right?
What happens when the anchor isn't terribly heavy, but the chain is incredibly long that moves us into the chronic grind
Persistent depressive disorder or pdd the clinical code for this is f34.1
And keek defines the criteria here as a depressed mood of more days than not for a staggering two years in adults
Well one year in kids. Yes, the intensity of pdd is usually lower than a major depressive episode
People with pdd are often highly functional like they go to work. They pay their bills. They interact with their families
Yeah, but they are operating with a permanently altered baseline of joylessness
It's like if mdd is a sudden category five hurricane that rips the roof off your house
Pdd is a two year long dreary drizzle. That's a great analogy
It doesn't destroy the house in one afternoon
But after two years of constant gray skies dampness and rot it profoundly damages how you live
And because the nature of the beast is different the treatment priority shifts. Okay, so what changes well while antidepressants are still used
Psychotherapy becomes the absolute central pillar because it's a chronic issue, right?
You are not just pulling someone out of a sudden storm
You are trying to rewire thought patterns that have been entrenched in a low gray dampness for years
Here is where the clinical detective work gets incredibly difficult though
Keek warns test takers about a phenomenon called stacking. Yes
stacking
A patient can have pdd and mdd simultaneously also known in the field is double depression, right? Exactly
Let's walk through how a doctor actually untangles this in like a standard 15 minute appointment. It's really tough
Yeah, a patient sits down and says they can't get out of bed. They're missing work. They feel completely worthless
The doctor sees the hurricane and the trap is treating the acute hurricane and assuming the job is done
Oh wow
If the doctor prescribes an ssri
And a month later the severe mdd symptoms lift the doctor might declare the treatment a massive success
But the patient is still stuck in the dreary drizzle
Right the doctor missed the fact that the patient's normal baseline before the hurricane hit
Was actually a chronic state of pdd
So the exam wants the clinician to separate the duration from the acute presentation
They have to ask about the patient's mood two years ago. Not just two weeks ago
Yes, because if they miss the pdd underneath the mdd the patient will never fully recover
The underlying chronic condition was completely ignored. That is such a subtle but dangerous trap
So we have looked at timelines dictated by calendars 14 days versus two years
But calendars are you know, man-made constructs very true
Let's look at what happens when the timeline of sadness is dictated strictly by the body's own internal biological clock
Okay, this brings us to premenstrual dysphoric disorder or pmdd
Code f32.81
This diagnosis basically removes the calendar entirely and relies on the physiological cycle exactly the defining feature here is absolute precise timing
Because the mood symptoms like severe irritability crushing low mood extreme tension
They only appear during the luteal phase, right?
Which is the week or so before menstruation and the moment menstruation begins the symptoms lift almost entirely
The treatment for pmdd offers a really fascinating look at neurological mechanisms
The first line treatment is an ssri but unlike mdd where a patient has to take the pill every single day
A patient with pmdd can take the ssri intermittently like only during that luteal phase week
Yes, and that is a crucial distinction that specific detail just blew my mind. I thought ssris required like
Four to six weeks to build up in the brain to have any effect
How can taking it for just five days possibly work? It comes down to the mechanism of action
Okay, break that down for me. Well in major depressive disorder
The ssri is working to block serotonin reuptake
Which slowly causes the brain to rewire its own receptors over several weeks, right?
That's the standard understanding but in pmdd the severe mood drop isn't a serotonin deficiency
It's a severe sensitivity to the hormone fluctuations of the menstrual cycle. Oh, I see
So the ssri even in low doses rapidly alters a specific steroid macabolite in the brain that calms the nervous system
It works within hours or days not weeks
So it's using the exact same pill for an entirely different biological mechanism
But to get that pill cake emphasizes a super strict diagnostic rule
A patient must provide prospective daily ratings across at least two cycles. Yes, that's the rule. I really have to push back on this
Okay, let's hear it
If a woman comes into a clinic and says I have a completely debilitating life ruining week every single month right before my period
Why isn't her memory of that suffering enough?
It's a fair question because forcing someone to do daily charting homework for two months just to get medication
I mean that feels incredibly dismissive. It feels dismissive for sure
But the intent is actually to protect the patient from the medical system's historic tendency to just dismiss women's pain
How does charting protect them? Well human memory, especially when viewed through the lens of a current mood state is heavily distorted
Ah, it's like looking backward through a funhouse mirror. If you feel terrible today
You remember the entire last month is being terrible precisely
You blur the timing and if a doctor just listens to the retrospective memory
The trap is waving it off at standard pms or misdiagnosing it as a generalized anxiety disorder or mdd, right?
By requiring real-time daily charting the diagnostic tool becomes a seismograph. It maps the exact biological fault line
Okay, I see that now. It forces the medical establishment to acknowledge pmdd as a verifiable
Neuroendocrine disorder driven by a biological cycle not just some vague complaint
So it elevates the data so it literally can't be ignored exactly kik pairs this focus on biological windows the parapartum onset specifier
This is for a major depressive episode that begins either during pregnancy or in the four weeks following delivery, right?
The mechanism here involves a massive neurochemical cliff, which is just wild to think about it is
During pregnancy hormones like estrogen and progesterone
Absolutely skyrocket to sustain the fetus and then the moment the placenta is delivered those hormone levels essentially fall off a cliff back to zero
The brain experiences a massive withdrawal treating this requires therapy and medication
But the clinician has to constantly monitor what is crossing into the breast milk, right?
Yeah, they are treating the mother's brain chemistry while safeguarding the infant's developing system
It's a very delicate balance. However, keek places a massive flashing neon warning sign over this entire section
The ultimate emergency trap missing postpartum psychosis. Yes
The exam questions will try really hard to trick the test taker into confusing a severe parapartum depression with psychosis
But they are entirely different beasts
Completely different the guide is so emphatic about this postpartum psychosis is not the baby blues not at all
The baby blues are transient tearfulness as the brain recalibrates
Psychosis is the brain entirely short-circuiting. The mechanism of psychosis is a break from reality, isn't it?
Yes, the warning signs are severe confusion disorganized behavior
delusions or hallucinations and often those delusions center around the infant like
thoughts of harming the child or bizarre beliefs that the child is demonic and missing this distinction is literally the difference between
Prescribing an antidepressant and preventing a fatal tragedy
If a doctor sees a new mother who is deeply depressed
But also exhibiting severe confusion or stating bizarre beliefs about her baby
Keek's rule is absolute you screen for psychosis and you hospitalize immediately
It is a psychiatric emergency that requires immediate anti-psychotic medication and separation for safety
Notice how the severity of the intervention scales with the mechanism of the disorder
You validate grief you medicate pmdd cyclically you engage long-term therapy for pdd and you treat psychosis as a life or death crisis
It's all about matching the tool to the exact problem, right?
Let's shift our focus to a completely different demographic from the biological cycles of women
We move to a diagnosis that the dsm committee literally invented to protect children from a dangerous systemic medical error
This is a fascinating one. It's disruptive mood dysregulation disorder or dmdd code f3 4.81
The rules here are incredibly specific to pediatrics
The onset of symptoms must be before the age of 10 and the diagnosis can only be made between the ages of 6 and 18
Right and the hallmark isn't sadness. It is chronic severe persistent irritability
punctuated by frequent explosive temper outbursts and the first line treatment approach
Entirely avoids heavy mood stabilizers. Yes, it leans heavily on behavioral parent training
Psychotherapy for the child and treating any underlying issues like ADHD
I have to say I can hear every parent listening to this right now. Just rolling their eyes. Oh, sure
I mean kids throw tantrums eight-year-olds are frequently irritable. That's just childhood
Right. So how does a clinician look at a kid having a massive meltdown in a grocery store and decide it's a psychiatric disorder
Rather than just normal developmental acting out
The key is the word severe and you have to look at the baseline between the outbursts
What do you mean by the baseline? Well normal childhood tantrums are reactive and they end the child calms down
But a child with dmdd does not return to a calm baseline. Oh, they don't know
They simmer in a state of highly disruptive angry irritability most of the day nearly every day
It causes severe impairment in school and at home
But keek points out that the true reason dmdd exists in the manual isn't just to label angry kids
Not all it was added to stop doctors from falling into the pediatric bipolar trap, right?
So two decades ago
There's this massive spike in children being diagnosed with pediatric bipolar disorder just because they had severe explosive tempers
Exactly, but true bipolar disorder is defined by its mechanism. It is episodic
It features distinct separated waves of mania and depression and keek hammers this point home for the exam
Chronic irritability is not mania
It absolutely is not and if a doctor confuses chronic childhood irritability with a bipolar manic episode
The harm is profound because to treat bipolar disorder a clinician prescribes heavy atypical anti-psychotics or mood stabilizers
Yes
And giving those to an eight-year-old brain is devastating the metabolic side effects of those medications on developing body are just severe
Very severe. We were talking about rapid massive weight gain metabolic syndrome lethargy and serious neurological risks
The psychiatric community realized they were effectively using a sledgehammer to treat a behavioral condition. So they built a new box
Dmdd was created as a diagnostic safe harbor. That's a perfect way to describe it
It gives clinicians a code to validate the severe behavioral disruption the family is facing
But it actively steers the treatment away from heavy anti-psychotics and toward family behavioral therapy
It is truly fascinating to see the diagnostic manual acting as a living document
Correcting its own blind spots to prevent medical harm
It perfectly illustrates why keek's exam prep focuses so heavily on the separators
A misdiagnosis isn't just a theoretical mistake on a test. No, it changes the trajectory of a human life
So how do we pull all of this together if we zoom out from keek's guide?
We see that modern psychiatry relies on an incredibly specific grid to map the murky waters of human suffering
Yeah to tell near-identical sadness apart clinicians are hunting for the exact separators
They check the calendar for the 14-day floor of major depression or the two-year chronic dampness of pdd
They track the biological clock for the ludial timing of pmdd
They assess the baseline irritability of a child to utilize dmdd and avoid the bipolar track
And they monitor the neurochemical cliff of the peripartum window to catch the emergency of psychosis
Exactly, which leaves me with a final thought for you to ponder
We started by talking about the desire for a broken arm x-ray
Right and this prep guide highlights just how rigid the boundaries of mental health diagnosis have become
Exactly 14 days exactly two years exactly an age limit of 10 very structured but human emotion is fluid
It's messy and it's infinitely subjective. It doesn't know it's supposed to wait two weeks to be considered real
The clinical mechanisms are very real. Yeah, but the lines drawn between them are often just human compromises
Exactly. It makes you wonder are these five disorders truly distinct physically separate diseases living in different neighborhoods of the brain or is this highly specific
Rigid diagnostic grid simply the best
Safest system we have managed to invent just to figure out which therapy or which molecule
Will ultimately pull a patient out of the dark. We can't see the jagged white line on the bone
So we build the most precise calendar we can and we hope it leads to the right cure